[Music]
welcome to life without labels
i want to talk to you about something i
wanted about the brain or rather
if the brain was a landlord i want to
talk to you about its tenant the mind
even brain or mind is extremely
complicated it's complex
it's been shaped by three billion years
of nature that means evolution and for
most of that time its main function has
really been just to stay alive keep on
reduce reproducing
play by the rules of evolution get on to
the next next one
but as we each time we evolve we grow
we get better and better mutations
changes
but that doesn't stop the fact that for
three billion years every living thing
in this planet has been rooted in the
natural world
including our ancestors of human beings
but then about two hundred thousand
years ago something very very strange
happened
we don't know what exactly a mutation
probably in the brain
but what it led to was a significant
change in the way that the human brain
works
what it did was cause a drastic change
to the way that human beings lived but
since that time has taken us into a
world
quite unlike the world in which we
originally spawned
and nurtured and if we're not careful
about that
if we do not understand this reason
behind this more clearly
and spread that information then human
beings are going to
no sorry nothing wrong with your
bandwidth i want to explain that your
brain is an anomaly detector
you're expecting the story beginning
middle and it's going to one more
the truth of the matter of course is the
brain needs patterns it needs
certainty what some philosophers call
closure
and when we don't get closure we had an
anomaly and the brain
the old part of the brain that's been
with us enjoying us very very well for
billions of years he's going to detect
that anomaly
and divert resources mental resources
towards it
it's going to switch off what else
you're doing and notice that
either a level or a major level and then
when it's safe go back to doing what
you're doing
so in a way then the brain is a
life-saving
anomaly detector it's a kind of a fight
and flight without necessarily having to
fight or flight
at the lowest level it's just a way of
letting you know that something's
happening
and also another function to the brain
it's social
ever since the beginning of time even
bacteria talk to each other
and human beings most definitely do
now to understand the brain better first
of all i want to have a
few words with you about the way we
think about things and brains in
particular
you see the sense we make of the brain
can only be understood
in terms of things already available to
us we cannot talk about a concept and we
haven't really got some
idea of the concept in mind we can't
just
use a new language because well the
person you're speaking to wouldn't
understand
remember with the social creatures we
have to connect
for thousands of years and hundreds of
thousands of years perhaps
the brain was understood as god or
spirit we could infer this we can't
prove it of course
from some of the bodies that were found
in neolithic grave sites where these
people appear to have had
holes drilled in the front of their head
why
these are clean holes to let the spirit
out to let
the devil out we don't know but the idea
that
somehow god and spirit and brain and the
mind are all closely tied together
that consciousness is soul is a gift
from god
are very very strongly held within us
it's only really in the last
500 years that the very strict grip that
god
and spiritualism of some sort or another
has finally released its grip on our
understanding of the brain
and that has opened a door to scientific
inquiry rational
scientific inquiry we'll hear more about
rational scientific
inquiry in a bit but what i want to do
now
is work look work back a bit
how do we get to this situation in the
first place
i want to go back to what life might
have been like or rather what a brain or
a mind might have been like
three billion years ago when life began
back then remember
you and i look pretty much like well a
bit like this
let's take this monocellular organism
the amoeba it's a pretty good stand-in
for the kind of creatures that were
swimming around in the sea
remember we were born and grew up in the
scene as a human race
many many zillions of years ago when we
look like this
notice how this creature has got a body
okay the body is somewhat wobbly it's a
thin membrane made of protein and
fat and lipids and things but it's a
body
outside the body is the gods making
uncertainty you might say the
mind-blowing uncertainty of the world
the universe
inside is warm it's stable what we call
housekeeping genes are keeping the
processes
inside the body running over smoothly
the metabolism
is keeping it warm keeping it alive and
active now
those genes believe it or not the
housekeeping genes are exactly the same
in you
and me and an amoeba in a potato
we haven't really changed nature is fond
of a good trick if something works
why not use it for the next few billion
years
this amoeba is moving interestingly
towards
a food particle yummy in the blue and a
way
you might see from the dangerous toxin
particle dodgy red
over there there's a line
there's one or two points called
receptors on the surface of that
membrane but we know this because all
cells have
that can actually detect something out
there in the world
in other words this living thing has
sensation
and it can take that information and
somehow change the substrate
inside the cell the contents of the cell
to store it
and somehow convey that storage back out
again
in the form of action interesting enough
those transmitters can also send out
signals when the thing is under threat
you can say help me or i would like to
mate with you
even amoebas are basically social
creatures
what we have here is basically the
fundamentals of the mind a
memory intent action response
and storage all these things come
together
now it was pretty soon that those
chemical messengers from one cell to
another
made mamivi clumped together they
realized that maybe two or three cells
or maybe live on an economy and scare
and do a much better job of staying
alive because as i say
staying alive and communicating is what
it's all about
so let's just pass forward now to maybe
half a billion years later let's look at
this little organism
i'll stay with you for too long but
let's just see that
this is the sort of creature that i've
been crawling around about half a
billion years ago
notice how the sense organs are now more
sophisticated there's a clearly clearly
an eye
and a nostril here and notice how the
center organs are slapping close to what
is now
a much larger brain and notice how that
brain is connected
via a long wire to every other bit of
the body
and every other bit of the body is
pointing back up and talking
back to the brain there is a loop here
body talking to brain brain telling body
to move
move shifts the eye the isd something
different
it feeds it back to the brain up a bit
please lift a bit please
it's an amazing fluid organism
let's now fast forward 200 000 years ago
to this gorgeous looking guy there you
go homo erectus
he's probably about 500 maybe so
5 000 human generations if we take a
generation is about uh
40 years this guy's your great rate in
search
of 500 there your great great great 500
grandfather
it's that close look at the guy what has
he got
he's now got his sense organs at the
front of the face not just the eyes
looking forward that's good 3d vision
notice that it's on top of about a fiber
of this game this hunk's case
a six foot high tower so he's gonna be
above
he's up right he walks but in this case
he crouches
and look at his right hand he's holding
or should i say
grasping something this creature is
heading places
something has happened to this creature
that has changed him out of all
recognition to his
squidgy predecessors what might that be
when you look inside his head you'll see
something really quite spectacular
let's compare his head say inside with
that of the possum or the rabbit animals
that pretty much
if we look at skeletal forms and fossil
forms haven't changed that much
look what has happened to the size of
the human brain
it had a kind of a cortical makeover
look at it a dirty great big cortex
sitting like a
cerebral mushroom on top of the stalk
you can just about see
poking out from the bottom that is
basically
a profound change and virtually all of
that mechanism
is devoted to storage and communication
i want to show you kind of technical
diagram now that goes inside that brain
it's a schematic rather than actual
drawing of the real thing but
please bear with me this is a diagram
of brain pretty much in a schematic form
and i want you please pay attention to
my cursor to see that it comes up from
the spinal cord
there is a torrent of information coming
up from the body
for the vagus nerve and into the body
and it arrives at the primitive the old
the ancient part of the brain
that hasn't changed that much since you
and i are squeegee worms
it's still working nature likes the
trick
this information is then filtered and
processed through
incredibly ancient emotional parts of
the old brain
what it does is it filters out things
and
it looks at all the other things that
have gone before in the terms of
experience
that are stored to continue watching
this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas